is your day long
is your day long yeah this is why the
home is a little bit in shambles I don't
blame you I simply think that you must
be tired and I can help you dear oh yeah
I would love that that's what I said
however she turned it and flipped it on
me and said this is your mess I'm like I
haven't even been here in seven days
this is not the case it's such a lie in
five four three two one
Hello everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast for
our first time listeners this podcast is
about anything and everything most
likely by the time you're done hearing
this you're either gonna cry laugh or
hate me we have a very special guest
here we have my short-haired lady
surely yes Muriel song everybody and you
burped in between my name yes I did Big
special announcement which I'm pretty
sure most people aren't surprised
because I didn't really hide it that
much but I never made a huge
announcement about it uh we are actually
married we're married yes for the
longest time I didn't announce it we
didn't really put it out there because I
didn't really feel the need to didn't
really care to and number one we never
we never had a huge ceremony no we loved
yeah we went to uh we went to the county
you're okay there you're about to barf
no we're good I just had a lot of uh
Lacroix but we went to the uh what do
you call it that spot the the courthouse
went to the courthouse we got we did the
whole Courthouse thing and it was all
good it was all fun and we did that what
last year
November
November October yes October uh what's
the date then 14th no no I'm just
kidding exactly you know you don't even
know your teeth is our regular
anniversary not in October though yeah
what is it in October it's August 14th
no no no our wedding anniversary what's
the date what what do you mean our
wedding anniversary what's our wedding
again what's the date I know what it is
no you don't do you know dude you don't
know I have it on my Instagram Instagram
I have it on my calendar do you it's the
19th of October yes you're 100 sure
[Laughter]
you know why it's hard to remember
because it was such a transactional
thing we didn't have like a ceremony
this huge huge huge thing yeah but I am
officially married I'm off the market
ladies why did you want to announce a
nail then huh because I have nothing to
talk about on the podcast I'm kidding
I'm kidding okay no it's been about a
year I think it's I think it's okay yeah
it's been almost a year I didn't feel
like um
I don't know I think like when you're
kind of in the public space everybody
has this thing where they feel like they
kind of are privy to the personal
information in your life and there's a
lot of stuff that I tell publicly right
I see like 70 of my life is public but
the other 30 I don't think it I really
care to tell people what's going on you
just want to cherish it in private until
because I was with you for a very long
time before I even we just hit our
eight year mark eight years eight eight
of the happiest years of your life I've
made you a better person
I I meant you have good skin so check
this out so before I before I met Muriel
I never use lotion I didn't believe in
that yeah you were crusty ass okay
that's a little disrespectful I look
when you're when you caught a grow up in
I feel like
for people who are listening that are
younger right you have a lot more
flexibility than things that you do and
you could do things with with a lot less
judgment right I mean it's still there
but prior you know like in High School
junior high everything was gay like
using lotion was gay really yeah dude
everything I think it's just because
like homophobia was so huge and it was
just it was just a quick thing to make
fun of people for you couldn't even use
lotion I was like oh what's up it's gay
boy using lotion so you wanted to use
lotion it's not that I wanted to it's
more like I needed it
uh-huh right I mean people would use
lotion here but people would always you
know try to throw a cages but it was
considered something very feminine yeah
right super girly oh girls girls use
lotion uh people are making fun of
Korean men in Korea because they use a
lot of like skin care
oh 100 look at it now everyone's using
it that's what I'm saying like the onset
of the internet and kind of people on
the the fringes that were made fun of a
lot they're they're the majority and so
if the majority speaks it's like yo I I
use face lotion all the time my mom used
to try to get I remember when I was a
kid This was um when I was like 14 and I
started getting acne my mom was trying
to get me to use lotion
skin toners she knew she knew hey use
toner use all this other stuff and I
used to get in fights with her because I
didn't want to use it I'm like using
this [ __ ] it was like 14 I was like 40.
oh yeah I mean it's like I'm not using
this lotion [ __ ] and then now I'm over
time my mom's like dude you didn't see
this new thing I got oh you have more
products than I do I'm actually using
your products now because they smell so
good I'm very very
very good with it but I've definitely
had like this point in my life where
like there's like a certain point After
High School you start to
maybe in high school for me too but
later on but as you get older you stop
caring about what everybody else thinks
I don't think it's for everybody like
that but as you get older your threshold
for [ __ ] gets smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller also you are not
in the same Circle as well like you work
oh yes you start hanging out with other
people and it's not really like
clickiest like oh you have to do this
trend or else like you're gonna get
kicked out of this group you know that
kind of I think in high school and
middle school you have that like I have
to fit in but once you go into college
it's like trying to identify who you are
so you try different things
at least that's like how I transition
it's like I don't care about fitting in
anymore I'm all about like finding out
who I am and trying new things yeah that
that moment happened for me happened for
me like Junior of high school so it was
then I was just like I don't even
[ __ ] care anymore because I'm not
gonna see these people anymore like
after I graduate I'm gone I'm out I'm
out this [ __ ] yeah like I'm not in high
school anymore I'll be leaving I'm gonna
just do whatever the [ __ ] I want that's
why when I was in junior high I or uh
not junior high when I was a junior in
high school I joined choir oh no way
yeah let me tell you something
that's why I joined choir because I
wanted to yeah they're laughing at me
right now this is this is my nightmare
that's super cool I didn't enjoy
anything I wasn't allowed to so well I
joined choir and I always wanted to join
choir but
there's this one moment that I'm like
completely scarred from so
every year they would somebody would be
picked to sing the national anthem oh
right so and you usually it would be
somebody from choir
um and the the music teacher at the time
Mrs Dake would be the one to choose
who's gonna won who's gonna be the one
um I always wanted to sing the national
anthem right wow never did it though you
didn't get picked I got picked I didn't
want to do it why not because the last
guy that did it somebody called him a
[ __ ]
but you didn't care anymore right no
like okay I didn't care about that but I
do care about getting laughed at by
every person in the school you know so
that this guy goes up and you know I
don't use this word anymore but I'm just
saying it for the story sake yeah he
goes up and he's about to sing he clears
his throat one dude in the crowd just
goes [ __ ] and everybody busts up
laughing and I got scarred I'm like I'm
not doing this because that's for sure
gonna happen to me yeah a hundred
percent but I kind of wish I would have
done it though
now is the moment you have the mic right
in front of you I don't care about doing
it now
those were those things like in high
school when you start when you when you
start becoming a little bit older you
stop caring so much and as even now too
I start carrying less and less and less
and now I'm trying to learn how to care
a little bit more so I'm not so
insensitive yeah maybe care more about
your wife you know and so all of those
conversations basically are thanking me
to uh get back on we care more about
your wife dude this girl yesterday man
she's so full of crap so so okay check
it out I've had covet right and you know
like when you have covid
if you guys have ever had it before uh
some people are concerned about you and
you know she generally was but this
woman was treating me like I had leprosy
like well yeah I didn't want to get sick
I never got cold today like she was a
vampire I could just cover her I'm like
yeah because you didn't cover your face
so I'm covering mine
okay okay let's not be dramatic so we so
I I had the the back Studio before
and then I turned it into a podcast it
was a podcast studio and now it's just
like a a lounge chill area so I was
sleeping there for the past five days
five or six days and on the seventh day
I decided to come back in the house
turns out I found out that this woman
is literally the loudest person in the
world in the morning hey what happened
when you found out you were negative I
gave you a hug
because then I survived too you
hyped yeah
yay got Kobe I don't know what my
symptoms are it could be the worst
very true and you're sick already so
who's gonna take care of me huh I would
have taken care of you no I was fine I
wasn't even that sick and what if I'm
like super sick you know I don't want to
be in that position I was trying to make
sure that we're both healthy people
anyways so I'm loud and what's your
point you know what I hate about her the
most on this podcast like her
personality is completely different than
how she normally is what do you mean
it sounds like you're speaking Japanese
but in English hi I just wanted to take
care of you that is the voice
all kinds of voice just like how you
have a loud voice in certain places
biggest thing that we argue about which
we don't really argue with fight that
much anymore
he loves it's like 10 o'clock at night
we're you know we're chilling we're
trying to cool out before we go to sleep
I just hear her just scrolling through
tick tock
is it wrong that would I be laughing and
I'm like yo do I need to get your
permission and be like oh
wait a minute are you a Japanese anime
villain surely enjoying my moment what
do you want me to not do that no it's
not that I don't want you to do that
it's just that you cackle so loud
and then we have this thing too I'm not
sure if you guys ever been like if
you're with somebody right and you're
trying to watch TV right you're watching
TV it's at a normal volume and also you
just here in the corner
but it's very normal in Korean House oh
yo I'm watching something here and I've
been begging her and I'm pretty sure
guys know this too I've been begging her
just to get headphones and by the way
she's had a brand deal well the brand
deal sent her seven thousand headphones
because he doesn't use them I do they're
all broke no they didn't there's two of
them in the drawer right now I gave them
to you
you could use them whenever you want no
you keep them see this you just don't I
don't understand how come you don't want
to share headphones well you have your
own headphones I do I do use it so use
them I do no you don't you just
you know okay if I use my headphones my
laugh or any reaction won't go in my
headphone you know that it'll still come
out and for you to listen yeah but at
least I'll mitigate one of them because
you've had that thing so loud
what is with that
my I can't hear I don't know if you
notice but I can't really hear
she's been doing this thing lately too
that's been getting on my last nerves
which is I'll literally tell her
something and then two seconds later she
goes hey if you ask the question the
thing I just told her there's a lot of
things on my mind it's like hey what do
you want to eat I want to eat
Mediterranean food because she's messing
me up right now
wow I want to eat Mediterranean food I
feel like oh that sounds really good two
seconds later
so what do you want to eat I'm like okay
Dory
what are we doing why are you doing this
to me you know my nickname is story ever
since high school and
you just love to blame everything on me
these days you know what happened okay
during covid I've been you know taking
care of him bringing food and whatnot
and then when he was done with covet oh
my gosh it felt like we went back in
time when we were dating on our first
year and it was so pleasant because he
was so nice I told him every time I was
like wow you are so nice and he's like
what are you talking about I'm always
nice I was like no whatever you're doing
right now keep it because it's really
good I love it uh well that didn't last
because only a few days after he just
kept picking on everything that I do I
was like why are you so loud why are you
so this why are you so that no no no
what happened this guy become very nice
me was a lot nicer too me she was the
Naggy one right she was blaming me for
the funny thing is I wasn't even in the
house and there's and there's like it's
a mess in the house and she goes this
guy over here just dirtering up dirty
I'm like I haven't even been here I only
mentioned it because you mentioned how
dirty the place was no I didn't mention
that it was dirty because what happened
to her house why is it such a mess
that's not what I said at all let's
let's rephrase it the proper way okay
this is what I said I said oh you
usually keep this place like super clean
have you been super busy
no
I don't know what they were oh and
because I said I've been very busy
because I said that
cool so no you didn't ask yes I did no
you didn't you just made a comment about
everything you process it is never an
attack I'm simply just dating I said my
dear it is are you stressed is your day
long
is your day long yeah this is why the
home is a little bit in shambles I don't
blame you I simply think that you must
be tired and I can help you dear oh yeah
I will love that that's what I said
however she turned it and flipped it on
me saying this is your mess I'm like I
haven't even been here in seven days
that's not the case this is such a lot
you know what let's sound thicker and my
first podcast in the studio because
we're not really behind the scene who's
you know getting to know me and Robin
can see the verbal abuse that I get
every day well here's sometimes after
this sometimes I just cry into my pillow
every night I'm I'm so happy this
marriage has been great she tricked me
she was like yeah and you're the one who
announced it and now it's too late it's
better if I announce that we're legally
married yeah
let me ask you something what
oh God so aggressive I'm trying to keep
up with your level here so mean oh my
God
then this show before you married me
what was the ideal man that you thought
you were there
oh you really want to know yeah I want
to know what is the ideal man that you
thought you were going to marry wait
this what is this is this a trap listen
I'm not a girl I have questions to trap
you and then throw it back in your face
divorce paper that's ready to come out
here that is the typical girl Trope that
a lot of guys say is that they ask
questions to go ahead and trap us like
oh do you think I look good in this
dress
yes yes and if I say oh there's a
different dress well guess what you
ruined my whole day I'm not doing that
so are you gonna answer the question as
well
because that's that's the trouble answer
the question I will ask the question 100
honestly that's fine do I Wanna Know do
I wanna know though
oh no you could you could you can
yeah you can sometimes it's just
ignorant is a bliss okay that's what I'm
saying you can ask the question if you
want if you don't want to then you
already answered it with no no you
already have you're looking girl is a
girl that watches Tick Tock silently
wow actually that's fine because that's
a very low bar right there yeah so let's
let's start with you before before you
met me or before you married me what was
the ideal man that you thought you were
going to be with my ideal man because I
know for a fact it wasn't me
my ideal map remember I had a whole like
a check box yeah what what's the what's
the list oh well you did check a few
things like I want to go I don't want to
hear any of that stuff I want to hear
the stuff that you I want it um I wanted
a guy who treated me like a princess
that's legit I wanted a guy who treat
how my dad treats my mom right now not
30 40 years ago right now which is
treating like a princess
um I know this is so girly of me but
really I wanted to explain to me treat
you oh no okay it's not a really
apprentices like of like you you know
what like okay
before we go into this explain explain
what that means exactly treat me like a
princess princess oh I was about to get
into that okay
um
it's more of
kind of like the old school style of
like you know taking care of me and not
like you know I mean you do take care of
me like feed me and all but who's
someone who's like you know has a what
do you call it chivalry chivalry
chivalry chivalry [ __ ] I can't pronounce
it right chivalry yeah of you know
opening a door for me kind of thinking
ahead I like to do that you know because
I'm like oh you're sick let me go ahead
and like make you not make you feel
could I open doors for a girl that walks
faster can I finish mine oh yeah go
ahead sir thank you very much you know
like when you're sick I go and prep food
for you and then you come back be like
oh thank you honey kind of that reaction
like I'm a verbal affirmation girl
that's my level I don't do verbal
affirmations like can I finish you ask
me what my ideal is it's not I'm not
saying that you don't have okay okay I'm
getting a little defensive go ahead oh
my god do you want this conversation
I told you my levels right here I'm not
gonna change it
um
yeah so I'm a verbal affirmation person
I love active service
I mean I don't think my bar was that
high who's able to speak Korean
understands the Korean and American
culture plus Japanese and Taiwanese will
be great because I lived in those
countries
um
uh who likes to do outdoor activities
with me who likes to you know get to
know my friends explore new things kind
of plan things out together
he wanted to do absolutely nothing
no no together because you know I'm a
very nosy person so I have to be part of
it makes me laugh so hard
to speak girls who want to be treated
like a princess usually behave like a
princess too well okay so that's the
thing I'm like it's not a typical
princess really because I'm not asking
you know I don't like to wear like but
yeah but you just use your mom as an
example your mom is very much like a
princess no he's my dad as an example no
but your mom and dad's relationship
because your dad can't treat your mom
like a princess because she has like
these princesses well that's the thing
the prince's role has been taken in the
family so I can't have that role like
I've never met a princess that farts on
their Prince's laps
so well the thing is that when I met you
uh you were like polar opposite of what
I had in mind sexy
very sound and sexy and dry
but you've also made me real I mean the
reason why I picked you or like we
decided to you know handsome
it's your personality it's because oh I
just just call me handsome already
you're handsome thank you man when I saw
that jawline coming around when you lost
that a lot of weight
I am a huge person when it comes to
jawline I don't know why it's a thing I
don't understand why jawline turns you
on it's from Smallville Tomlin had a
really nice jawline I'm like that
jawline looks amazing I mean the man
that was a 40 year old dude that played
an 18 year old he was 30 and he played
uh yes 18 year old and he looked very
young
he was in his actually mid-20s when he
started okay fun fact anyway
uh but yeah you had some of those
aspects you know
um there are some that don't but can't
be perfect what's the don't uh you don't
plan with me you don't do after
activities we have complete different
Hobbies
here's the thing
I do a lot of outdoor activities her
outdoor activities it's so funny because
verbally she'll say she wants to do
something but when it comes to it unless
it's a trip I'm talking about out of
state or something like that then she
has no energy to do anything which is
crazy because I like to explore the
local area because there's so much stuff
to do here her on the other hand like
here's here's something for example we
have gone to this place called Eaton
Canyon yeah
three times in a row and all the three
times that I went with 30 never finished
it she went almost right to the end and
the end is the best part and that's
where the waterfall is I've been there
at the End by myself I think we didn't
have enough time or something no we did
each time you're just
so tired I was like I could have been
very tired okay we will go back or the
other time it was I'm so hungry I could
have been hungry three times we have not
been able to complete that hike and it's
a hike that I did probably about five
times a week at that point for a month
straight well that's the thing you build
up your endurance I didn't
no I'm talking about from the first time
that I did it I went all the way through
the first time I did I went all the way
through not with me yeah I did you're
talking about recently exactly that's
what I'm saying like recently I've been
there before a long long time ago I know
I'm saying recently three times in a row
you didn't complete it and that's why I
was like we're not doing this anymore
yeah it's not our first time it's
recently and yeah I'm talking about the
first time that we started again
and that's that's because you filled up
your endurance and I will go biking
right and she goes the weather it's too
hot it is yeah because for me I just
bike whenever
you have different tolerance and I'm
with and that's fine the thing is like
I'm very outdoorsy now is you have so
many conditions but if we go outside
somewhere it's like she could walk 40
000 steps forever but when she walks do
yesterday we walked a mile and we had to
stop
I'm so tired I looked at my stuff so I
was like 1500.
1500 it's quick because in Korea we were
walking an average of like 17 000 steps
a day the energy is very different David
the energy of going to a new place
seeing people just seeing new
environment is very different it brings
Joy
so much joy walking though is Joy it's
meditation
oh sorry uh that's the thing your I
don't know how you walk for hours and
the Heat without anything I'd be so
bored I hate walking first of all I hate
walking
but I love walking like in Tokyo in
Seoul because there's just so much to
look at I'm very distracted I'm just
like wow there's a lot of stuff around
here and I get to get you know I'm
entertained but if I'm walking and
there's just
landscape of brown mountains everywhere
and the air is Dusty and the cars are
just vroom vroom vroom by
that's not entertaining for me I just
want to go home but walking for me Isn't
a point of entertainment so like walking
is a point of number one it's
activity
it's for activity health and also
meditation so there's no I'm not looking
to be entertained when I walk so here's
the thing like I said we have polar up
very different Hobbies because these
Hobbies Define very differently for us
NAMI so that's what I'm saying I don't
understand how you can walk 17 000 steps
and then walk a thousand and then look
like you're going to explode I don't
know like you look like you ran away
from a lion run away from a lion like
full speed what do you mean
I had a leg day workout two days ago and
so I was feeling this way
I answered your question so that's what
it is is that I want to do a lot of
things together but I also want to have
separate lives in our own independent
lives with our friends and whatnot and I
think we but we actually have that we
have a rule
like if we don't need to go to the
wedding you don't have to go
like if there's if there's a wedding
where
you don't
where I let's say I know everybody right
and she has to travel for it she doesn't
know anybody at this wedding she doesn't
have to go I I don't care if she comes
or goes right if it's a wedding where
it's like I know a few people and that
she also knows everybody that's going to
be there then yeah let's go together
because it'll be fun but if not then
it's just like introducing you to like
400 people it's just this is whole
ordeal you know because I already hate
weddings as it is which is probably why
we haven't had one yet it's just I just
I just
like for example if I'm going to go to
this ratchet ass Vietnamese wedding
she's probably not going to go
not her vibe
is about to get [ __ ] crazy
you know yeah and it's around very
specific people that she she normally
isn't around yeah so for her
I just kind of say I know like for
people's like oh it'd be nice to meet
your wife or whatever whatnot well if
you want to meet my wife then you could
meet her at any other given instance
aside from just a wedding we could get
dinner we could do all other stuff if
it's just for that idea then she doesn't
have to come because it's just point
it's pointless because I know these
people I'm gonna have a great time right
and we're going to talk about old
stories we're going to get drunk we're
going to do crazy [ __ ] and she doesn't
have to be a part of it and for her and
no offense a lot of the wedding she has
taken me to have been absolutely [ __ ]
boring because
in terms of very not nice because in
terms of the weddings that I go to It's
So Different right and what I mean by
Boring is like it's the weddings that I
really really dislike it's like it's
very high it's hyper religious
so hyper-religious weddings are very
very ritualistic right and so that's
more of a formality there's only one
another like that the other ones weren't
like that
what are you talking about
anyway
I think my friend's weddings are fine
well for you that's what I'm saying and
well I'm not saying that what their
wedding is not fun for everybody else
I'm saying for me right so you like
ratchety stuff hell yeah hell yeah so
here's the thing we're yin and yang yeah
very different two different worlds
coming together and fortunately there
were some mutual interests in that
diagram and that's what we like to share
and then we have our own separate lives
with our separate or different or our
own friends and family yeah her group of
friends are very different from them
very different my group of friends are
just weird they're very weird you got
eccentric variety of friends yeah like I
feel like every friend that I meet from
her I already know who they are like
they they kind of have very similar
backgrounds they're usually they grew up
very religious like church people
especially specifically the girls
the ones that you grew up with come on
CE who I grew up with it's only Becky
what are you talking about all the
Korean girls that I met they're all
hyper religious oh okay yeah Korean
girls yeah yeah so it's like and those
typically are the weddings that we're
gonna get invited to here and there a
lot of them are turkeys too yeah and I
think that they're very good people
that I grew up with not the best so like
they still I like your friends no
they're great people now but they
weren't when they were younger so they
still have so when you see these
weddings some of the most ghetto [ __ ]
ever but that's the that's the part that
makes it really fun right you get to see
the most craziest ratchet [ __ ] that
happens I have to say going into your
friend's weddings some of them wow it's
like another like it's it was an
eye-opening of knowing what the culture
is like because like I went to Indian
wedding Vietnamese wedding oh Vietnamese
wedding Indian wedding wow they are
fascinating I have to say it is a lot
more entertaining than you know typical
Korean and that's what I'm kind of you
know accustomed to right and so but it's
not for you to be entertained it's like
giving them respect to the friends and
family over there
that's understandable but I still have a
choice to whether I want to attend this
or not right because I don't want to go
to somebody's wedding and then look all
pissy you know what I mean because I
think that's even more disrespectful I'd
rather celebrate with them by buying
them a meal having dinner with them and
then you know congratulating that way
first is me going to a wedding where I
just don't care about anybody here
there's terrible music the food is not
that great and I'm just sitting here
just doing
listening to the speech that's this best
man speech that's terrible I'm still
gonna ask you every time because I
prefer having you around and but I will
give you the choice of saying yes or no
I always ask her is it something that I
have to go to or something that you want
me to go to and if it's something that
she wants me to go to I will
if she goes I need you to go to this
then yeah I'll do it like I'm not
griping about it or whatever I just need
to know I need to mentally prepare
myself because when I when he says yes
there's for some reason God is on his
side or something there's a work
issue where work kind of overlaps with
that day of I'm like what what is this
this is some Lottery like but he ends up
not going
and guess what Papa gotta make money so
I gotta do it yeah papa got her okay
yeah yeah but that's why I trade off
like I don't there's definitely a few
ways that you didn't have to go to I
knew you wouldn't have enjoyed so I was
like it's okay I just went solo dolo and
it was perfectly fine people do find it
weird though when I show up without you
really of course because you're my wife
and so if I show up without my wife
though is everything okay it's like no
everything is great she's over here in
Canada
I think she's having a good time I'm
over here no that was fine one thing was
interesting is that when I went to
Canada and Bamford I went to Toronto and
Banff I you know for Toronto I went to
go see my friend Bob I went with my best
friend and then when I came back and I
was telling people about it they're like
you didn't go with your husband I'm like
no I went by myself I'm like wow and
he's okay with that I was like
I hate that phrase though I I really
hate that and it's not because of their
judgment on it because I think that's
perfectly normal in terms of like what's
socially well socially normative in
terms of a typical relationship
I don't like the phrase he let you
like what do you mean let like what is
this idea you know what I mean people
will say that too about you know YouTube
it's like oh she let you when he let me
like this I I don't
and I I want to say it's because it's
very social narrative because I've seen
it in a majority of my friends
relationships they do everything
together and if they don't do it
together they get upset or they feel
left out I don't have that one of the
things that I required before I got with
somebody in a very serious sense was
that this person had a life without me
and the reason why is maybe it's because
I love to be alone I do like my alone
time right which is why I like to walk
by myself and like kind of process my
thoughts it's meditation for me right
yeah and there's certain parts of my
life that you don't have to be a part of
yeah you don't have to and the reason
why too is look I know this is very
morbid and Grim but what if I die
no like legit what if I die and your
whole identity is based on
everything we do together versus you
know developing yourself as an
individual yeah yeah right and how I
always looked at very strong and stable
relationships was
uh you are a Powerhouse in your own and
so am I when we come together we're
something else so I want you to be able
to enjoy life with me which are the
Great Moments too but also have your own
personal time and have your own moments
so when somebody says that phrase oh he
let you it's like dude what do I [ __ ]
own her she's not my possession she has
her own life she could do whatever she
wants yeah and I think a lot of people
number one they feel fomo and they also
get really jealous yeah right they're
like oh what if they're out there and
some guy comes up to it did she'll
[ __ ] handle it there's no what's the
problem here what is going to happen and
if let's say worse comes to worse she
does cheat on me then guess what I'll
leave her ass then then I'm still good
life is okay
my lovely genius farts this podcast is
brought to you by athletic greens you've
heard me talk about athletic greens so
many times because I use it every day
and I don't promote stuff that I ain't
using and I use athletic greens my
friends just get your day started right
because what is this stuff it's one
delicious scoop of ag1 you're absorbing
75 high quality vitamins minerals Whole
Food Source ingredients probiotics and
adaptions to help start your day right
with the special blend of ingredients it
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging and all these
things help you out my friends invest in
your health it is one of the best things
I have ever done you guys know I lost
like 100 pounds in the last three years
and on top of that too what I put in my
body is so important I didn't realize
that until later in life and that's why
I take my ag1 to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune support in
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com
geniusbrain again that's
athleticgreens.com geniusbrain to take
ownership of your health and pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance
yeah yeah I I mean
let me understand when I go to weddings
and I see you know all the couples are
together and they're asking where's
David or like where's your husband
um sometimes I'm like I wish he was just
here then I wouldn't feel I feel fomo
not having her around yeah
um but at the same time I like the fact
that we have this Mutual understanding
that hey sometimes like we're just gonna
do our own thing like we're gonna fly
you go to Hawaii and like having your
time with your dudes and I go you know
somewhere with my friends and we're cool
with it yeah yeah and of course like we
talk about it and we like make sure
there aren't any other events that we
have to go like if it's family uh events
and stuff like we always discuss about
it and we make sure that we're clear
that you know yeah this is like
I always just need a heads up and she
knows this too because like even though
I I have a very
I'm very sociable by skill not by Nature
so it is something that I practiced a
lot you're very good at it right like I
could talk to a [ __ ] doorknob if I
wanted to but
I'm glad you say Dory I thought the word
Dory was gonna come out like I could
talk to just about anybody have a great
conversation it's just a skill I develop
but that [ __ ] drains me and she knows
after we do these events or we're around
like big family or everything else and I
feel bad because I understand that but I
have a big family
you don't have to feel bad I just need a
heads up it can't be oh by the way we're
having a family party tonight I'm like
nope that's not gonna happen because you
can't do it I can't do it because number
one I is
I'm going to be overloaded well that's
the great thing about us is that I like
to plan ahead I don't do things on the
spot if I do I plan that ahead as well
yeah if he has a really really big
family which is something that I'm not
used to I never I never grew up with the
big family because a majority of my
family is in Korea so for us like our
family were my parents best friends and
they were my uncles they were my aunts
because we didn't have a lot of
relatives and so the friends that we had
in the states were the people who also
didn't have a lot of family here either
so we became each other's family and
then every Thanksgiving we would meet up
and those are the things that I kind of
missed when I was younger because
everybody moved away so now Thanksgiving
is super super small now Christmas is
really really small which I I guess is
fine it's just kind of how life is same
here I mean Grandma when Grandma was
around she was like the glue of the
entire family but you know after she
passed away everybody was so busy with
their own lives you know that everybody
my aunts and uncles become became
grandparents for their kids and so you
know they have their own family that
they need to celebrate with so we ended
up like just having smaller you know
events
um but once in a while we do try to get
together you know like my cousin from
Chicago came around with her son we want
to make sure that we could all like have
a dinner together it takes a lot of work
I mean you know because everybody lives
so far away from each other they all all
have their own lives
um but once in a while when that comes
around like you know we try to make an
effort because at the end of the day
like We are family you know and if
something happens
you know that at least
you can someone maybe I don't know
potentially rely on them or like know
that you have someone around you don't
see your family a lot though my family
are my parents
my family
yeah I mean because everybody has their
own
busy life we do but we do talk a lot on
social media
what do you mean
so like my cousins we all chat up online
oh okay yeah so that's how we keep in
touch and so when we do come around it's
like we kind of know what's happening
with each other's lives so we kind of
talk about that it's like well how was
that event that you went to or like oh
like my cousin one of my cousin-in-law
uh went back to school to be a teacher
again recently and so I was like oh
how's that and she's like oh how did you
know that I was like you know seeing
what you're doing on social media it's
like you know and so then we talk about
it
um yeah we do talk about getting
together but it's hard because everyone
their parents you know they have to work
around their kids schedule too
yeah and I like like with her you know
we were talking about this just to go
back to the wedding topic
I don't care about weddings because my
parents don't care about weddings
um
my parents are very practical human
beings when it comes to like
practicality and money-wise stuff as
long as we were married then
everything's fine if I never had a
ceremony or a party or a reception or
anything else like that and I was on my
deathbed I would never regret the fact
that I didn't have one that's how I feel
about weddings like weddings to me are
once again when I say these things it is
not a reflection on what you like is a
reflection on what I prefer I think
weddings are trash I think damn you
don't have to say that harsh but I
genuinely feel like that though so
because you know if I were to expound on
that weddings are not for me it is for
everybody else and I refuse to spend 50
000 on other people so if it really is
like in celebration of me I shouldn't
even have to pay for this [ __ ] so
I just don't think it changes the
quality of my life it doesn't change the
quality of Our Lives it doesn't change
the fact that I love you doesn't change
the fact that we'll maybe one day have
kids uh it doesn't change it doesn't
make me happier I I will never look back
at a wedding and be like man dude this I
don't think I would ever do that
if you have a wedding would you see that
as like man my wedding is a trash
it's not that wedding is trash it's like
if it happens then it happens right but
I will never ever put effort into
wanting to have one
if it's important to you that's
different but there's a lot of things
that I don't care about that's important
to you that I make it important to me
because it's important to you do you see
what I'm saying so if you're asking me
personally then no I could care less
about it's such an old and archaic
version It's just old as [ __ ] and I know
a lot of people are saying well I just
want to celebrate it like I said that's
fine I don't give a [ __ ] what you want
to celebrate I'm saying that I don't
care and people have a huge problem with
that people have a huge problem me
saying I don't [ __ ] like weddings and
they go oh look at this guy like I don't
why don't you like it because I have an
ability not to like these weddings
especially somebody with anxiety
especially with somebody who just like I
say I'm very practical in that type of
sense where I want to do something that
I feel like I'll enjoy like if I have 30
[ __ ] thousand dollars I'd rather take
that and travel the world um I
understand a certain degree because I am
someone who doesn't like to be in the
spotlight to begin with I have anxiety
to be in front of the crowds so the fact
that I have to put so much effort and
money just to be in the spotlight that I
hate to be on
um it gives me a lot of stress so like
before pandemic we were thinking about
having a wedding so I was trying to
figure out like you know what are the
options out there and I was so stressed
out because one I'm trying to figure out
how to be you know good with you know
find like the best costs first of all
but it's so expensive and then I have a
lot of family
and they're everywhere and then think
about accommodating like I didn't
realize how much of
uh compromising
stuff that I have to do for the wedding
and I'm like is this really fun for me
because it's not well if I'm saying like
the wedding isn't for us it's for
everybody else it is so I mean they say
do what you want to do so that's what at
least you know my American friends are
saying do what you want to do don't care
about others it's for your one so I took
that mentality and I'm like I'm gonna do
what I want to do and then
yeah I forget that we're Asian and it
comes I didn't I didn't know this or it
didn't hit me until
I talked to my Asian community and
they're like no this is for your people
not for you like this is for them to
know each other like two families come
together and like introduce each other
you have to think about and I was like
wait so I have to think about like the
kids and everything I don't want the
kids there the funny thing is that I
don't think your family knows the only
people they're going to be introduced to
are my parents none of my family and so
even so and so when I when I was like I
was thinking of just adults only it's
like you can't really think like that I
was like what
because for me now it's like oh well
that's what I'm saying so upset I was
explaining to her too and I'm very
empathetic towards her because
I don't have family politics because I
don't have family here so for her I was
trying to explain to her because she was
stressing out and basically what I was
saying that is your your
path is going to be very different from
mine right because you have family
politics there are so many things that
you have to consider people that you
don't invite will get butt hurt and
because it's within this family web that
information travels to somebody else
people are going to feel a certain way
um and that's just how you guys are
there's there's a double edge there's
two things to it what is great because
you have Community right people care
about each other they love each other
that's all fantastic but because of like
that proximity and how close you guys
are people are also uh more prone to
getting hurt by these type of things
yeah for me I've developed a reputation
in my family of somebody who could give
a [ __ ] less because I am the son of my
mother and so my mom has that reputation
too so for example I'll give you a
really good example I have a a nephew
who isn't he's doing a lot better now
you know who you are but you are a
[ __ ] loser and I can't stand [ __ ]
like that because those type of loser
ass qualities that I see in him is stuff
that I saw in myself when I was younger
and he's still doing the same stupid
[ __ ] even though he's older so uh
problem with him is that you know his
father's pretty well off and he likes to
fix his problems with money my family
never did that we don't fix we don't fix
problems with money we fix it by having
real solutions and kind of talking
through things so for him basically my
uncle was telling me to throw him a bone
and you know basically uh get him a job
and stuff like that and uh he wasn't
telling me he told my mom this and my
mom laughed at him and my mom told me
that she goes I laughed at him I was
like why'd you laugh at him she goes I
told him is that were you scared to ask
me this and he goes yeah because you
know I know who you are he goes if you
ask David that it's going to be 10 times
worse he's like he is my son and he's
worse than I am so and she's right if he
would have asked me that I would have
chewed him out because of course our
family's So Different yeah there is no
look my mom has tact but the way we do
things is very head-on and very
straightforward we don't like the
[ __ ] about anything and I did and I
got that from my parents so I know with
your family they're normal yeah
you know
imagine what Korean family would have
yeah yeah and I'm not used to that you
know my parents I don't know how we came
together
it's so weird because you accepted
you knew that you're gonna accept this
family that is polar opposite of you and
have you know we're very complicated
because of that because we have to
consider our culture
you know reputation and
thinking about others considerations and
stuff and like somehow what made you
just like think yeah I'm gonna accept
that I didn't know I was going to jump
into this oh really it just happened and
I accepted it wow you didn't think
there's a lot of things there's a lot of
things about in our relationship that I
didn't expect but I I accepted it
because I wanted to be with you and it's
not a it's not a make or break type of
thing right for me to be your husband
and say oh you have too big of a family
there's too many family politics uh I
don't want to be a part of this
relationship anymore it doesn't make
sense to me because it's not like what
your family is doing is toxic it's not
like what your family's doing is
terrible it's just something that I'm
not used to so I can learn to adjust to
that and make those adjustments I just
need time right so if for example you
know listen your mom is way different
from my mom
like I said this before I told her this
and she didn't know who I was talking
about her mom dresses like Katt Williams
like
she goes like a pimp
fancy she's fancy she is fancy she's
she's yo I remember so when we came back
from Korea right
now
I saw her I was like yo your mom is fly
as [ __ ] and we may be very typical like
Korean culture uh type of family but
when it comes to my mom's fashion he's
like where did you come from like you
know and yo she'd be having some nice
ass [ __ ] I remember she had this uh it
was this multi-colored uh Louie bag I
was like yo that thing is [ __ ] dope
like I said I mean I want a purse but
I'm like that's pretty [ __ ] sick and
she had this Louis bag I was like dude
she knows what's up my mom on the other
hand this woman straight up the fatty
pack
I love that side of your mom the fact
that she could care less yeah they're
polar opposite I mean give and take
right my mom's all about fashion and
being the best of the best super funny
yeah and she's very funny
um however she doesn't cook yeah she
does not because she doesn't she doesn't
do any wife material like the old school
wife material she doesn't cook
um she's then she doesn't cook that's
all I could say and your mom on the
other hand the best chef ever I've been
eating her food every day so good yeah
so good I mean I cry every time I go
because the food is so darn delicious
yeah my mom expresses her love very
differently than your mom does right
yeah and I think your mom is equally as
loving she's just different right the
the similarity part is that they're both
very funny yeah and they're very
um they're very sweet they could they
know what they can convert very well too
yeah you know after we came back from
Korea it's so funny I've been seeing
like these weird little level UPS from
her parents in terms of their affection
towards me right they changed but
literally it was they changed uh 180.
there was no gradual no I don't know
what happened I know what happened is I
went to Korea and I met all of her
sisters and I met her dad's best friend
they spoke really really well of me to
your parents you were
because it was already like that with
the other family members right but now
like everybody that I've met they really
really liked me and so I met Muriel's
dad's best friend and then we were
chopping it up having a good time and
you know just a really dope conversation
he was really really cool and I liked
them a lot and for sure because they
talk on the phone all the time he said a
lot of good things about me yeah even
after that your dad was this like my son
I was like my son
and it was so funny when he said that
[ __ ] because I was sick from covet
recently and then he called me and then
we were chopping it up for a little bit
here and there and now the conversations
are a lot more casual before it seemed
very forced like he wanted to talk about
random things which he doesn't have to
do right because he's now my dad
and then he's talking to me and he goes
and I was like oh in Korean I was like
you know so thank you for calling you
know I appreciate it and he goes of
course you're my son I was like the [ __ ]
like how I mean in a good way I was just
kind of shocked yeah and then the other
day I walked into the house and then she
hugs
he goes oh my son
your parents on the other hand when we
just met they already started calling me
daughter-in-law and I freaked me I was
like
that was my day that was my dad yeah and
so my mom got pissed so my mom actually
took him aside when he did that after we
left I freaked out my mom was like what
the [ __ ] are you doing you don't have to
pay for my mom is right she was pissed
at him she was like you need to stop she
goes that is super uncomfortable like
they are they they are only together
recently they're not even engaged don't
do that [ __ ] and then my brother too
chewed him out for that [ __ ] too so
you're being [ __ ] weird
I mean now it's fine yeah because we're
married but like before my dad just
comes on so [ __ ] strong it's because
he's really really happy you know yeah
yeah I could see that it's not there's
no bad intention to it oh no I'm just
telling like yo relax bro like I just
got together with her I think what's
great is that your parents my parents
anything us too we're all so different
but I think it's good because we check
on each other of the things that we see
that you know you may not see yeah yeah
yeah I think your parents do that very
well my parents for sure do that well
and I think maybe that's why we attract
each other we're just so like we grew up
seeing our parents being polar opposite
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're just attracted
to opposite personalities yeah your
parents are very just very very
different yeah we're very different your
parents are very different when I see
your whole family Dynamic I I'm tripping
because you actually met my Aunt
remember my aunt and you you think my
mom's rough my aunt's worse
um well I admit you're on I've seen your
videos yeah yeah I've seen videos
um where she was rough but I think when
I started Thanksgiving she was a lot
more soft she's not a very soft person
at all that woman is rougher because I
was there I literally saw this woman
bite my other aunt in the face exactly
she had rabies
my family's [ __ ] crazy dude so she
she's a very interesting person like
like I'm saying like
I feel like the Korean family that I
grew up with is very atypical
you know because when I tell these
Korean stories a lot of Korean people
are like I don't know if there's a
Korean thing I think that's just a your
family thing it is I don't have to say
though I
I think I'm still gonna try to plan a
wedding no I said like that's fine it's
been forever yeah I just told her that
you know to go back on topic was
you know when you plan the wedding you
have to be really considerate of
everybody that you're inviting because
of your family Dynamic it's not
something that I have to deal with if
somebody comes up to me go you'd invite
me to your wedding I'd be like get the
[ __ ] out of my [ __ ] face don't talk
to me see that's where I'm like what
yeah I'm like listen if you want to hang
out we can hang out we could do all this
other celebration stuff but I didn't
feel like it was necessary for you to be
there and plus I didn't want to be at
the wedding so I hope
one I think initially I was like no we
don't need a wedding maybe just like a
party or something but all it comes down
I was like you know what I hope if we do
have a wedding which I think we should I
hope it could be uh intimate and
memorable where we're like this was war
this was it was worth it if the wedding
list is like I don't know don't put a
number in don't put a number let's just
say if it's like I don't know like a
hundred people then it's good then it's
a lot easier for me because there's
plenty of people that won't come yeah
most likely there's not going to be a
lot of adults on my side
huh
Oh you mean like
our parents adult or because I don't
have a lot of adults so it would be I
don't have a lot of
um my my parents too just like me they
don't [ __ ] with a lot of people so they
don't have a lot of like friends they
have a set amount of close friends
everybody else can [ __ ] off so
um
that's easier for me for a smaller thing
if it becomes bigger than I'm inviting
all these other random people I'm not
trying to make anything bigger just
because yeah because I feel like the
people that you're going to be inviting
is going to be all your family if your
family alone is going to cover up 50
people
yeah you know for my family it's not
going to be that big I see half of that
will be maybe like 15 people will be
like quote-unquote people who are family
and the rest are just going to be people
who I invited and if they want to go
they can if they don't then whatever
Abdul is that
you have a wedding it'll come down and
be like man that was worth it
that's what I hope not like huh this
this was a trash it's not that the
wedding isn't trashed once again because
weddings are trash in general it's I
just don't like weddings I don't like
the idea I hope you end up liking your
own wedding
I will cause I'm not gonna plan it
I'll help you want it on my husband's
side we plan to gather David I will help
assist you yes be my PA yeah I'll be
your PA I think the hard part is once
again is that because this is such a
grand grandiose event and it's not
really for us it's for other people I I
dislike it it just goes against
everything that I am as a person so once
again anybody who has weddings out there
don't take this to heart I think
weddings can be very very dope it's just
for me and the way that I think I I
don't like it very much I give kudos
those who could do weddings or I'll say
this though Tim's wedding was dope
why because the ceremony was super
[ __ ] fast it was beautiful there was
alcohol flowing from the beginning to
the end dope ass [ __ ] music uh really
good food dope dessert and it was just a
party you know which is the weddings
that I usually typically like to do
um
but
I don't know I don't really care for it
will help you care for ours because
I don't want to be the only person we're
uh we're a family and we do it together
no I'll help you I said yes I'll help
you and once again our wedding I'm not
saying that it's trash I'm saying that I
the the idea and the concept of weddings
this is how I feel about it right once
again if it's important to you it's
important to me
that's all okay everyone heard that okay
that's it if it's important to you it's
important to me there's a lot of things
when we early on in our relationship I
was trying to explain this concept to
where we're
this is not how it is now but we'll go
do something right and then I'll do
something for like for example I hate
Magic
I'm not a big fan of Matt she took me to
Magic Castle right and then you know it
was a perfectly good time and then she
was like oh I didn't know you liked
magic I was like no I hate magic and he
was like
so upset at me because she goes well if
you didn't like magic why did you go I'm
like no
I went because you wanted to go and
because it made you happy I was happy it
doesn't necessarily mean that I enjoy
magic I hate Magic Castle I hate it when
every random person came up to me like
you want to see a card I'm like get the
[ __ ] away from me how
did you mentioned the magic one I
thought you were gonna mention about
Disneyland no no no well Disneyland's
another one too at the time so yeah for
me
I went to Magic Castle and I did the
whole magician thing because I saw how
happy it made you so it made I enjoyed
it because you enjoyed it right I
enjoyed the fact that you were having a
good time the experience itself I
[ __ ] hated it but we were together
and you were you were amazed you're like
wow I'm like okay this is fun now fun
fact it was probably it was actually the
first and the last time they ever went
yeah but once again like that's what I
was trying to explain to you early on is
that not everything has to be done
because I specifically enjoy it I can do
things and enjoy things because I enjoy
being with you
you know what I'm saying if that makes
sense yeah would you enjoy being with me
if you go to weddings
I can but like I said if you want me to
be there I'll do it but you also
understand the reason why I don't like
going to weddings because it's a
questionnaire for me
questioning oh man I saw you on that
Netflix show oh man you know what I mean
it's like a meet and greet every time
every time it's a meet and greet and it
it's not a bad thing right but then like
during this time where sometimes I just
want to be ambiguous and I just want to
get to know other people or maybe just
talk and chop it up it's always me doing
a questionnaire at this table and it's
exhausting for me right it can't be like
oh what do you do and you know how
everybody [ __ ] responds every time I
ask that question hey also what do you
do with oh I'm doing something as cool
as you I'm like okay well [ __ ] this
conversation then dude like this I'm
just gonna be talking to myself about
myself for 45 minutes and it becomes
that every time and it becomes
exhausting so even when I go out of
state and I see other friends they go oh
do you say oh I want to go to we're
going to have a little a party with
friends I'm like I don't want to go
because every time we just party with
your friends guess what happens it's me
in the middle of a circle and I'm
entertaining like [ __ ] 20 or 30
people
and that's why sometimes it's hard for
me because I don't ever get to have fun
when I go home to Sacramento and one of
my Sacramento friends uh has this party
guess what happens nobody gives a [ __ ]
about me we only give a [ __ ] about each
other in terms of our friendship and we
talk about I get to see what they're
doing get to see their kids they talk
about their lives what they're excited
about and it's a normal conversation but
I feel sometimes because there's this um
with your friends
um or not even your friends it's people
who are at the wedding and because I've
been on the space for so long
um sometimes it's hard for me to get to
know people or even have a normal
conversation because it's me just
talking about myself and it's just the
most like narcissistic thing that I
could do for the next like 45 minutes to
an hour and it's exhausting because I
don't even care about myself like that
that much I mean you could just make it
short right be like oh this
is you know no I can't even do that
either because it's
it's a representation of who I am as a
person right and when I'm there too like
I don't want people to feel a certain
way I don't want people to feel like I'm
irritated you know because I'm also
representing you too there's a lot of
things that kind of go into this like
this moving Parts I totally understand I
mean that could be very stressful
because you don't like attention that's
the first thing happens yeah it's like
okay put it on my face I'll you know I'm
a comedian that's what they are known
for if I do anything else I might think
I'm an a-hole that might impact to other
people so it's also a reflection of you
too yeah so I I don't want to reflect
poorly on you so
um which is weird too that's why
sometimes I don't even know if I'm
really made for entertainment because I
don't like attention which is the oddest
thing
if you're in entertainment you love
attention I don't give a [ __ ] who you
are if you are trying to make a career
and entertainment you have to love
attention you need a certain level of
narcissism and because you you kind of
feed off this praise and you want to be
recognized for this talent and this
performative art right so you are
narcissistic in this and I'm saying that
like in a terrible way but you have to
[ __ ] with yourself that heavy in order
for you to be an Entertainer the most
successful actors the most successful
entertainers they they admit I [ __ ]
love the attention
but the difference is is that at least
you get attention for a skill and a
craft that you're perfecting right I on
the other hand
don't really care about that I just
wanted to make people laugh and if
people laugh whether it was uh you know
admittedly so I wanted to be a major
stand-up comic when it first started but
after a while you know being on YouTube
and being on the space for 10 12 years I
feel like I've gotten everything that I
wanted out of being an Entertainer that
I really enjoyed and the difference
between that and maybe like other stuff
is that when you're on YouTube you get
to create for yourself and you don't
have to go through red tape yeah so
whether I get recognized for this stuff
or not yeah when it blew up and I was
making money off and then I made a
career off it it felt really good but
the objective was just for me to create
and have fun right it wasn't for
somebody to walk down the street and say
oh I know you from this video oh I know
you did that the thing that's not the
thing that makes me happy the thing that
makes me happy is when I see somebody
say hey I've watched you since I was a
little kid you'll help me get through a
lot of tough times because you made me
laugh that's the stuff that I really
really enjoy but the idea that the
attention is on me is not what I like I
like the fact that this person felt
better because of something that I did
which is the the effort that I put into
the art and the craft which is a little
I don't know it's a little complicated
kid you know you want people to get some
kind of
outcome like it feels good if you if
they if their life changed because of
you and changed in a good way yeah like
go through hardships and stuff you know
you do a lot of funny videos but there
is a message in some of them yeah it
really helps them and once again you
know just to not I don't want to
make it sound as if you know when I go
to these events or whatever somebody
asks these questions about me or they're
asking about me I'm like oh that's not
what it is it's just that sometimes it
sucks for me when I'm trying to have a
reciprocal conversation and it's just me
talking all the time and it's how boring
is that [ __ ] you know like how how
shitty is it that I know for a fact a
hundred percent
that when I ask somebody what do you do
for a living how they're going to
respond to me is I'm not doing something
as cool as you and then the conversation
ends I'm like okay
um what are we doing here yeah you know
it's like well nice to getting you'll
pick it up you're going to hear it a lot
now that I told you this like you'll
hear it all the time now I I had a hunch
that that was one of the reasons that
because you get so much Spotlight and
certain things and you just want to be
quiet
um I know that that was one of the
reasons it's just and I I totally see it
too is that you know they're curious
about you they want to know more about
you or like that's why when I go to
certain events when you know when I'm
like oh the population might not be the
best place for David to come then I
don't know and the curiosity is fine I
think it's just
um maybe I just don't like it when
people downplay their own lives against
mine because I don't when it's not it's
not a conversation you're just giving a
speech basically exactly that's what it
feels like it feels like I'm giving a
speech yeah you know you know and it
just I hate myself for it too it's like
who the [ __ ] do you think you are just
you're talking about you're like you're
not that special you don't like to do
that that's not like a thing that you
like to do you like to learn yeah like I
like listening to other people talk
about their lives of stories which is
why I have so many stories on this
podcast because I love listening to
other people to talk to me about their
lives it's one of my favorite things to
do like when I meet new people and they
tell me some cool [ __ ] story I can't
wait to hear that right because there's
life lessons in that there's so many
things that I could pick from it there's
some stories that I can share on this
podcast and that's what I miss
collaboration that's what I don't have
that's why I want to see you all the
time and talk to you all the time and I
laugh at everything because I have
nothing else to collaborate with what do
you mean you have nothing to collaborate
with me that's I mean no I totally
understand that because I love listening
to other people too especially if it's
like quality conversation you know and
it's like wow I want to know like how
you think like that and how you got
there
um and so I understand that because like
I also like some people would
when they asked me questions about my
life you know whether that's about you
or about my career
I mean I like to give my like I'll I'll
talk about it but at the same time I
will it's even more of a quality
conversation if I could also feed from
them and like what else like tell me
about yourself too because I want to
know how you got where you are right now
yeah and like how they're thinking and
that's the collaboration side I really
love it and that's what you like that's
why you like having these podcasts
because you're like I want to hear about
you I want to get more out of you and
vice versa like you also share about
your stories yeah it's yeah I mean
you know I'm kind of like navigating
towards that idea of when people ask me
what I do for a living now you know what
I say what I do food
I'm a business owner yeah that's what I
say too it's so much easier because now
we there's questions that we could ask
each other and they could expound on
their lives and they don't feel like
they have to make themselves small
around me right because I do have a very
big personality I get you know I'm loud
I'm rambuncious you know I'm a
Storyteller I could do all this other
stuff you know so but when that becomes
like my role in every group that I have
to go to it feels like I have to perform
every time and sometimes I I get into
the space where I feel like I'm letting
people down of their expectation of me
right because I am an Entertainer and so
that part is the part that [ __ ] me up a
lot and I have yet to be at a wedding
unless it's a wedding was it's friends
that I already know and there's other
people who are also in the entertainment
space where I didn't feel like that
right
or people would feel a certain way if I
didn't do something like that that's
probably more on me but once again I
would appreciate sometimes if you know
when we have conversations uh it's just
not always about me you know there you
go
well guys that wraps up this episode of
The Genius brain podcast
uh you catching your spring every
Sundays at 12 p.m you can catch Mario at
Mariel underscore underscore song on
Instagram and everything else as such uh
genius brain merch I'm not sure if it's
dropped yet I don't even call it merch
it's a collab uh with secret society
um [ __ ] dope by the way like we've
been working on this [ __ ] so hard
specifically edric my my business
partner because the design that we did
is very very complicated and
um but it has to be right before I put
it out because it's not really merch
it's it's a part of our contemporary
fashion it's art it's a [ __ ] art
piece so
um keep an eye out for that two years
playing every Sundays at 12 p.m we'll
see you all next time
[Music]